Thursday edition of PFT ot Hall of Fame
game coming tonight topics that we
didn't get to today during our two hours
together on PFT live Cris but I want to
start with something that we talked
about a couple of times and I want to
put the exclamation point or the
question mark or the ellipses that to be
continued on the end of this Tom Brady's
contract expires after this season we
don't know what's gonna happen next do
you think that Tom Brady ultimately will
go the route of Joe Namath John Unitas
Peyton Manning Tom Brady and play not
Tom Brady Brett Favre it was going well
until I got to that point and play for
another team before his career ends no
freakin way is that happening
none I mean you could just put that on a
period right there how about that one
just periods over don't even worry about
it one you know I think Tom Brady
everything he's done in New England you
know his family being there all of that
okay in the New England way that you
talk about I don't think he'd want to
deal with another organization because
he's just so used to the way things are
done so remarkably well in New England
that I think it would frustrate the hell
out of them to go to somewhere else
which is gonna seem like almost
second-rate to him too
you know this I mean his he might as
well be Tom Kraft Brady I mean he should
he's part of the Kraft family and like
you've heard we heard Tom Curren say he
thinks Belichick is gonna back off when
it comes to negotiating the the Brady
thing and all that I totally believe
that he probably is he realizes this is
a Kraft Brady thing he's got nothing to
do with this one and he'll let them
figure it out and just go okay let's do
it so I don't think there's any way Mike
there was a report last week that no
deal is coming for Brady anytime soon
and I guess anything can happen during
the season the concern for the Patriots
would be that at some point he is gonna
fall off the cliff and he turns 42 in
two days yeah so they have him for this
year when he's 42 next year
spoiler alert drum roll please he'll be
43
and at some point he's not gonna be able
to do it at some point you are going to
have invested a lot of money in a guy
who all of a sudden can't do it and
that's what the challenge is gonna be
for the Patriots now let me flip it
around okay because Tom Brady has spent
the bulk of his career scared to death
of Bill Belichick showing up one day
saying you're not worth the financial
investment you're not as good as you
need to be we've got somebody else who
can do it better than you and he's used
it as motivation but it's also been a
constant in his life what if he gets
through this season he doesn't have a
contract for next year we don't know
what the Patriots are going to do we
don't know what he's going to do what if
you're another team and you're a team
that has a pretty good collection of
players and could just use a quarterback
to push you over the top and there's
always teams that that are in that
mindset that are in that mode I apart
from what he can do for you as a
football player think about what he can
do for your business and I know that
it's not prudent for owners to launch
the preseason press conference by saying
we just really want to make a lot of
money this year but they really just
want to make a lot of money you're gonna
make a ton of money if you have Tom
Brady you're gonna sell all your tickets
instantly you're gonna sell hundreds if
not thousands of Tom Brady jerseys the
idea of a Tom of a 12 Brady jersey that
isn't white and silver and blue the guys
still moving merchandise unlike anyone
else from a business standpoint the idea
of being able to pilfer Tom Brady for a
year or two is gonna be too tempting for
thirty-one other owners to collectively
say he's not leaving he's just gonna
stay with the patron well yeah hey man
do they make a call maybe at the end of
the year to the agent or something like
that I mean I mean to what you're saying
it's very real yeah I mean he would do
remarkably well for any franchise where
he went to he's gonna make them a ton of
money he's Tom freakin Brady I mean you
know he's maybe the most notable
superstar in sports history in America I
mean he's up there with Michael Jordan
Babe Ruth and LeBron James and Muhammad
Ali at this point so you mean you're
right I just don't think first of all I
don't think money is gonna matter to him
I mean he's already proven that it
doesn't matter and I just think he's got
it he's a routine guy I mean you know it
that he gets to bring his trainer in the
building and he's got everything the way
he wants it in New England and I think
he's finally at the point of his career
worried I'm sure he goes home like you
said and it's like pella check so
annoying I'm sure he has days like that
now damn I wish he'd stop yelling at me
but I think you know ultimately he's got
a nice little niche for himself there
and the New England franchise how about
the Dolphins
well yeah yeah I hear you okay yeah how
about him I know but you know you're
just you're going down crazyville right
now just stop crazyville
he was to go to the Dolphins and do a
rebuilding that's what he wants to go
top three hey but I want to rebuild
hey how about see you later Jimmy
Garoppolo welcome home Tom Brady to the
Bay Area the team that he was there for
the catch game that's great stories you
can put this all in your next book you
write about
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports